y francia finalmente planea relajar sus
medidas contra el hobbit 19 la
flexibilización constará de cuatro
etapas desde el 3 de mayo hasta el 30 de
junio una esperada noticia para muchos
franceses que podrán reabrir sus
negocios como estoy feliz me hace mucha
ilusión al mismo tiempo no entiendo muy
bien por qué una tienda pequeña como la
mía tenía que cerrar porque puedo
calibrar el número de clientes que
entran y salen exo en la primera etapa
se permitirán los viajes entre regiones
y los estudiantes de secundaria volverán
a las aulas aunque los cambios
sustanciales se verán en la segunda
etapa el 19 de mayo se abrirán las
terrazas de bares y restaurantes con
seis personas máximo por mes a los
comercios sin museos entre otros siempre
con aforo limitado en la tercera fase a
partir del 9 de junio se habilitará el
interior de los cafés y restaurantes'
aumentará el aforo a 5000 personas en
eventos masivos y se permitirá la
entrada al país a los turistas vacunados
o con una pcr negativa finalmente a
partir del 30 de junio se espera acabar
con la mayoría de limitaciones como con
el toque de queda
y mira por completo tras reducirse
progresivamente con un inicio a las
nueve de la noche desde el 19 de mayo y
a las 11 desde el 9 de junio no obstante
el gobierno ha aclarado que la
reapertura es posible por la vacunación
pero que podría paralizarse con el
primer caso de la variante india en el
suroeste del país y con más de 5.800
pacientes en las unidades de cuidado
intensivo